as i was saying uh i made a tweet
earlier where i said we were all talking
downstairs and i was thinking about what
might happen
and i said my current thoughts are
basically the media will call it for joe
biden
yep meaning they're projecting him as
the winner
but donald trump is going to take it to
the courts end up winning and then the
narrative will be
trump stole the election like they did
for you know george bush is a little bit
different
and i get inundated with these lefties
and they're saying things like tim's
making excuses he's crying poor baby
like trump lost and i'm like i don't
really i don't really
like i want trump to win but i'm not
going to cry about it it's like and not
only that republicans did an amazing job
uh holding looks like they're holding
the senate they've made
what five gains now in the house sean
parnell's winning yes
so it's not some blue wave it's kind of
everyone's shrugging at each other
right now it's like there's like low
energy i think scott adams tweeted even
the looters are confused as to what to
do
everyone's kind of like i don't know
what happened is kind of like a
but uh anyway the funny thing is i'm
getting all these people tweeting at me
like
they're desperate for angry
conservatives and trump supporters to be
like crying and dropping to their knees
and i don't think they understand the
reason why everyone makes fun of them
not just conservatives
there's regular people who are watching
these videos of them shrieking and it's
like because you're
nuts yeah exactly look if joe biden wins
i'm gonna be like
i want uh joe biden to do the best as
the president i'm not gonna drag him
down like they did to trump for four
years
i'm really worried about reinvigoration
of the obama administration
he's going to i feel like he's going to
put our troops back in the middle east
he's going to find an excuse
exactly these peace agreements are going
to start going under uh you know onto
rocky ground
and critical race there is probably
coming back he's going to sign a bunch
of these wacky intersectional policies
that will strip the rights away from
several people under the guise of giving
them rights there's a lot of things i'm
worried about with a biden presidency
but you know and this may be to the
detriment of the rational
centrists the enlightened centrists
conservatives and liberals
in that well they used the riots
and people still voted for them they
were able to coerce and threaten and
scare people but for some reason
biden still end up doing really well so
again i got to stress we don't know is
going to win
now uh i want to make sure i clarify
project veritas says they've got like a
ton of crazy stories
oh i've heard if anything is going to
come out that might make a big shift or
a big splash i think project veritas may
have something
we'll see but uh right now joe biden
and it's good project veritas does have
something we are not going to discuss it
because none of us want our youtube
channels deleted
i'll discuss all of it are you kidding
me tim i thought we had an agreement
before we started this
they demonetized i covered i covered
project veritas catching that
harvester lady and they just they
demonetized it and told me that i was
mentioning things that could result
in voter voter intimidation or whatever
and i'm just like wow intimidate them i
was like
i talked about one lady i specifically
said in the video
there's not widespread voter fraud but
you should consider the power of one
person with thousands of votes
so this is important right veritas
uncovered that woman
who uh said for 55 grand she would get
them 5 000 votes
you see this yeah right now in nevada
joe biden's lead is about 7 400 yeah
less than eight thousand yeah that's
what we were looking at
earlier that's why it's like very
serious that you know for for youtube to
be like we're gonna demonetize this okay
well there's still a lot of people to
watch it
no they should blast that stuff out
there they should be like everybody
watch
this is what can't happen and we take it
seriously
by hiding the stuff what ends up
happening is people see that in the go
why is youtube hiding this they don't
want to know what's going on
no they should they should assure people
and say we take it very seriously
when we hear breaking news about fraud
we want everyone to know because it's
very serious
social media censoring this is something
that you should look out for
right you know as opposed to as opposed
to um
it's not proven it's conspiracy theory
it's just not it's like well
let's just like you know keep we're
investing
if you see something say something right
right no no unless it's
unless it's bad for the democrats yeah
exactly no no what you're if you're
if you're concerned about election fraud
then what you're supposed to do is to
wait until after the election is over
and then claim for three and a half
years that the president colluded with
russia despite the fact that there's
zero evidence that that occurred
can we pick a country right now for
biden oh um
of course kazakhstan is even better
better borett yes
okay they put up they put up a memorial
do they really
yeah that's right bo biden and that
proves and they named a highway after
that that does prove it it's true there
it is
in the bag for biden yep so how do we
get this out there how do we get
a special prosecutor and go after biden
i'm kidding didn't win yet yeah
they're actually going to take this
seriously and pull the video down like
this insane conspiracy theory
you know what's funny it's like when i
when i tweeted that the media would call
it
i got a bunch of people even even vosh
was like tim the media doesn't call
elections
it's like are you even watching the news
right now
they literally do call them they don't
certify them what
what is this like all of these lefty
journalists are like fox news calls this
for this
calls this for that calls this state for
this person they do they make calls
that's literally what the point of the
media is
well i think they're the only ones who
should be allowed to the new york times
the new york times made that very clear
and i trust them with everything
so yeah the contacts the new york times
tweeted it's like what do they say like
the job of the media
like only the media to call the election
something like don't let the candidates
call the election isn't it funny isn't
it funny that uh
i think they said something or twitter
said that they would not allow trump to
declare victory
and so trump has been like technically
not declaring victory
i mean his tweets are pretty great and
some of them i think one got deleted
yeah
did we ever get to the bottom of whether
or not that was a typo whether or not
twitter deleted it because he reposted
something similar
and i was looking uh at his feed and hit
like one of his tweets when i opened it
had this whole little like caveat issued
by twitter about how
this could be um harming the integrity
of the election
there's something stupid like that but
in the meantime joe biden
on his website yeah says once all the
votes are counted
we will win it's like uh yeah
statements can you imagine if trump
trump says trump is
positive about winning and it's like oh
my god it's
voter suppression i guess i don't know
you know but when biden does it's like
yeah you know old man yeah once the
votes are counted we will
we got biden's website says keep the
faith when all the votes are counted oh
is it not coming up why is it not coming
up oh it's kind of weird
this is not joe biden's website well
we're not showing this by russia
for a nice change of pace whatever fault
here that's weird
i'll check the connections oh heavens
carry on carry on please
the joe biden website says when all the
votes are counted joe biden will be the
next president of the united states keep
the faith sure now there are some news
outlets that did call out biden for
declaring victory because his lawyer
came out and said we're
we're winning we've won yeah and you
know
i guess he could technically say he
meant that we've won certain states and
not necessarily having had like
prematurely declared he won the election
but
and then like they both kind of gave
these kind of weak victory decorations
yes
like trump is like and frankly we won we
did win or whatever it's like he didn't
exactly
very good yeah it was a good election we
did great
and then i gotta i gotta i gotta be
honest man that there's two things
i'm seeing a lot of like have you guys
seen the sharpie gate thing
um no i i saw you you were talking about
this earlier and i saw a few tweets
mocking it but i didn't actually get it
so there's
there's people saying right now that in
arizona they because they knew trump
supporters come out in person they were
giving them sharpies instead of pens
so the sharpies would bleed through and
ruin and spoil the ballots or whatever
this is not true to the best of my
understanding there are several local
outlets that i've talked about
for some time that sharpies are actually
preferred it's
it's better for the machines but this
was days ago they were saying this yeah
so look maybe um i think that would be
weird and all you got to do is check
you know to make sure your ballot was
counted it will take some time so
that's going to be interesting but
man if you if you think that the
maricopa county elections board was
purposefully putting out misinformation
to screw over trump supporters on
election day
then why wouldn't you think that for any
other county was like it's like
just pick them you know what i mean
which county and then just say okay
they're
doing whatever i don't i i don't see it
it
it's it's a very emotional time right
now yeah people
people are just looking for
excuses essentially you know it's like
well this you know trump's
appearing to lose arizona because of
sharpies
but but he didn't lose yet and actually
that's the thing they've
called it for the associated press i
believe is called arizona for joe biden
but they've also i mean they haven't
called georgia or north carolina for for
trump but that's kind of silly i had a
whole bunch of people
on my twitter go uh andrew what
you know what what's gonna happen with
this i'm like they're gonna be counted
who cares like
it's you know even whether they go
through the machine or whatever
you know if if they were given sharpies
right
uh that's you know they could just chalk
it up to
voter uh poll worker error and something
and and that's it
they're not going to suddenly discount
thousands of votes because of
of uh that's not going to happen
sharpies you know
and that's and that's definitely well
because the signatures on that
match and everything what if for my mail
these trump lawyers would fight but it's
not even an issue
yeah so what are these the lawsuits i
believe uh georgia north carolina are
being sued as well as
uh north carolina or no maybe not north
korea pennsylvania and georgia
pennsylvania and georgia that's correct
okay so right now in arizona joe biden
has 51 percent to trump's 47.6
biden has 1.413 to trump's 1.321 million
however at 9 00 p.m maricopa county is
going to be dumping
a ton of uh bouts and the trump campaign
says they're going to swing heavily for
trump
about 60 percent of the votes that come
in should favor trump and they only need
57 so they think they're going to end up
winning arizona oh
friday interesting i think i think it
said friday now
trump must win pennsylvania that's it
now
he definitely needs to win nevada or
arizona he can win with either of these
so far it's looking bad for trump in
that capacity
but this is just the media this is
ap calling it the associated press is
saying based on
84 of those reporting in arizona
joe biden has won trump is saying is it
84
look at this actually well we can't pull
it up we can't look at this i'm sorry
84 expected total vote reporting and
then
over in north carolina they haven't
called it yet with 94 reporting
yep and trump is up uh about one point
uh what is that
1.4 or so points and then in georgia 97
percent
but trump is only up by point two right
now i don't know no no no no no no i'm
sorry i'm sorry point nine well trump's
uh trump's people are they're saying
that
once they're going their math by by you
know their equation
they think that trump's gonna do you
know have like something with four to
eight thousand
extra votes in in arizona right right
uh but ap it's like they're saying
arizona's gonna be 10 to 30 thousand
that's true
okay uh but but the ap saying oh no
we're calling it
and you're like well the media has been
completely right with all these polls
and everything yeah
exactly exactly of course we should
allow them to call it
we should we should start trusting them
now yeah
thanks for checking out this clip from
the tim cast irl podcast we do the show
live
monday through friday at 8 p.m so come
back to check us out when we go live
don't forget to subscribe hit the like
button hit the notification bell
and we are also available on all podcast
platforms for
free if you want to listen to us there
thanks for hanging out and we will see
you all
next time
you